over the past six decades lasers and
laser based devices have become
indispensable in many areas of society
with its long range narrow beam that can
be focused into a tiny spot a laser
provides high power of a small area and
this is of course useful for cutting
drilling welding but not only that it's
also useful for laser surgery and laser
skin treatment the laser is truly one of
the many examples of how so-called blue
sky discovery in fundamental science
eventually may transform our daily lives
the Nobel Prize in Physics for 2018 has
been awarded for groundbreaking
inventions in the field of laser physics
- Arthur Ashkan jacquimo
and Donna Strickland and all these three
will be giving talks
unfortunately dr. Ashkan will be giving
a tour by proxy but nevertheless sends a
greeting Arthur Ashe Caen is an American
physicist born in September 1922 in
Brooklyn New York as an undergraduate at
Columbia during the Second World War he
worked part time at the Columbia
radiation lab building magnetrons for
the US military Raider systems
receiving a BA in 1947 Ashkan moved to
Cornell here he studied nuclear physics
for doctoral degree deciding in the end
not to pursue a career in this field
where his older brother Julius already
was a renowned scientist participating
in the Manhattan Project obtaining a PhD
in 1952 from Cornell University Ashkan
got an invitation from his former
supervisor at Columbia said momen to
join the Bell Labs and started working
there
researching microwaves before switching
to lasers he was the head of department
of laser science at Bell Labs Holmdel
for over 20 years from 1963 to 1987 from
time to time also filling in as a member
of the technical staff ashcans dream was
to trap and manipulate atoms and in 1986
he and his colleague Steven Chu Nobel
laureate 1997 demonstrated the first
stable optical atom trap later known as
optical tweezers Ashkan then focused on
developing the tweezers to capture and
study living things like bacteria algae
red blood cells without harming them his
success has a huge impact on biological
research allowing for instance to study
how infectious organisms attack healthy
cells although still active
unfortunately as I said before dr.
Ashkan cannot be with us today
he sends a greeting though and a close
associate dr. Rainey Jie s young boy who
will give the talk in his stead and so I
invite dr. EC on were to join me on
stage
[Applause]
[Music]
I marvel Ashkan I want to thank the
Royal Academy of Sciences for the great
honor or Nobel Prize and you know I
can't be here for the when the time
comes but my friend Rene who's a fellow
Bell Labs man very good friend he's
gonna deliver the lecture in my place
and well okay I hope you enjoy it thank
you so it is a great pleasure to be here
today to deliver the 2018 physics Nobel
Prize lecture about your asking as you
just saw on the video we prepare the
presentation together and it reflects
what you wanted to discuss today so this
lecture is on optical tweezers and the
application to biological systems
first I will present a few historical
events that shows that our art art was
interested by the action of light from a
very young age then I will talk about
the early days of optical trapping light
pressure the origin of laser trapping
optical levitation and then I will
discuss the work that was recognized by
the Nobel Committee optical tweezers
laser trapping of biological particles
and then biological application of
optical tweezers in 1932 art was ten
years old and he was fascinated by the
Crookes radiometer so a crook 12 meter
is it looks like this it's a four veins
that are linked together and suspended
on the pinwheel each of the veins have a
dark side a black side and the other
side is highly reflective I like to act
as a mirror and all of that is within
the glass bulb with partial vacuum so
when light shines on a corridor meter
the black side start to move away from
the light so it start to move in this
clockwise direction here so the crooks
pedometer is moving due to thermal
effects in 1944 when art was 22 years
old I'm 22 years old he was working on
the post magnetron like was mentioned
earlier it was at Columbia radiation lab
so he decided one day to shine this
magnetron to the diaphragm of a phone
earpiece and magnetron was operating at
one kilohertz and he saw a one-kilo
trace on the co scoped at the time he
thought it could be radiation pressure
it in 1966 a few years after the laser
was invented and demonstrated art went
to a conference in Phoenix Arizona where
he saw a video by rosin and in the video
you would see the particle inside the
laser in the internal beam of the laser
to start to move in straight line and
bounce around and at the time the author
artist runs on it in May suggested that
it could be a few different things one
was light pressure
the other one was thermal effects so art
calculated what the light pressure will
do and figured out that it could not be
a light pressure so after a few months
everybody settled to say this it is
thermal effect but the main impact of
this video on art is to reignite his
interest in light pressure so what is
light pressure
so let's consider two different type of
objects a metallic mirror that is a
highly reflective and a transparent
small sphere so when a photon comes and
hit a mirror if it's the tiny mirror is
going to start to move in the opposite
direction to conserve the momentum as
the photon has been reflected and the
mirror goes in the other reflection
direction for a power one watt this
correspond to a force of 10 minus 8
Newton which may appear extremely small
but let's look at a transparent sphere
that is one micron in diameter so it's
very small so if we shine light on it
let's say we have a photon that arrived
at the upper part is deflected downwards
and the sphere will start to move
upwards in in reaction to the photon
changing its direction
the momentum is conserved if the photon
arrived in the lower part of the sphere
it deflected upward and the sphere goes
downwards so this is the basic mechanism
for this trapping if you have two
photons going symmetrically located the
small sphere will go forward for a power
of 1 watt on the one mic was micron
sphere the acceleration can induce on
the sphere is on the order of 100,000
times the force of gravity so the
radiation pressure that appeared to be
very small on a very small object like a
transparent sphere can be you can
produce tremendous accelerations so now
let's consider what happened if the
sphere is not exactly on the axis of the
laser as it was in the previous slide
but now is 1/2 axis so what will happen
to that sphere the transparent sphere so
the laser as of course higher intensity
near the center and the laser goes in a
direction and low intensity at the edges
so as we saw in the previous animation
if a photon arrive and the upper part of
the sphere it's good it will be
deflected and it will be a force for on
the sphere if the photon arrived at the
lower part the force in the other
direction on the sphere so that the sum
of the force can be decomposed into two
forces the scattering Force which make
the sphere move in the direction of the
beam a gradient force that makes the
sphere goes toward the center of the
beam so what is very interesting here is
that the sphere will be attracted to the
high power region of the laser which
seems a little bit counterintuitive but
it actually happens so the sphere goes
towards the center of the beam so let's
look at a little animation
so the photons arriving here more photon
at the top because it's near the center
look more or less photon here and the
ball was thought to move toward the
center of the beam when it's at the
center it just moved forward to the
scattering force and here it's going to
hit a slide but microscope slide let's
stop the sphere so the sphere is trapped
like the beam on the left and by the
microscope slide on the right so art got
the idea that because he saw this
phenomenon that he could actually put
two beams counter-propagating and put a
sphere in the middle the transparent
sphere and this fear would be trapped
because the scattering force of this
beam and this gaseous form of this beam
would be a comfortable composite each
other and the particle will be in
equilibrium there so that's part of his
notebook in 1969 and this notebook was
signed by Arequipa and Peter wolf two
famous scientists on their own and the
signed by our two Ashton on September 8
so here's a little animation on this two
beam trap so all the photon arrives
symmetrically so the net force on the
sphere is zero and doesn't move so this
is the first all optical trap so art
decided in the next year and 71 to look
at what will happen if it takes the
laser and turn it upwards and use
gravity as a force to to to produce the
trapping so here's the laser so
initially the sphere is sitting on
microscope slide then we turn on the
laser but it's too low power the sphere
is not levitating we increase the power
more photons and the sphere will start
to levy
and eventually this at the height that
it is determined by the laser power and
the beam divergence so I decided that he
will try to measure the charge of the
electron using an optical Liberator so
here's the setup that was in 1980 so
there is a sphere that is liberating and
there is a feedback control where he's
monitoring the height of that sphere and
it changes the power of the laser to
keep the height the same so then he
shined UV light in the chamber that
created electrons and he applied
difference of voltage something similar
to the Milliken experiment so the chart
did the sphere started to acquire
charges and the power of the laser is
adjusted automatically to compensate the
electric force that the sphere will
under go under this difference of
potential so here are the measurements
so you can see that this is the charging
time so how long the UV light is on and
this is the power of the laser needed to
levitate and you can see as the UV light
shines and charges are created on the
sphere the power to levitate changes and
of course it's actually step exactly by
the power by the charge of the electron
is a discrete power change that
correspond to the charge of the electron
and this is a very high accuracy
measurement of the electron charge using
optical imitators now let's talk about
optical tweezers the term optical
tweezers have this coined by art himself
and he has been rewarded for the Nobel
Prize for this work so what is optical
tweezers
so a laser here that goes to high
numerical aperture microscope objective
focus the light very tightly just not
too far from the objective and what
happened is that if we look here at the
zoom in this location at the center here
the minimum size of the beam the waste
of the beam the highest power is in the
middle here then there is a gradient in
the transverse direction that any laser
have it has more power near the center
of the beam than on the edges but now
because of this very tight focusing the
there is a gradient of power along the
axis of the beam so now from the center
here to going forward there is a very
big gradient of power and what is the
impact of that so we have learned from
previous slides that a sphere is
attracted towards the region of high
power so the sphere will experience a
force that's called a gradient force
that is not forward but is backward so
it's the sphere wants to go back to the
center of the laser and if you have a
sufficient focusing then this gradient
force will exceed a scattering force
that is always there and produce a and
attract a small sphere towards the
center of the beam but not exactly at
the center there is a bit offset where
there is a maximum gradient of light so
the sphere will settle just before the
focus so in the single beam you can
track at you can trap a small very cold
transparent particle so let's see it in
operation so here we have an optical
imitator which will be used just to
bring the spheres next to the tweezers
on top you have the optical tweezers so
the sphere is at the bottom of the tank
you turn the laser on so the tweezer
here as it's a fixed power
very high intensity need the focus point
then there is low intensity levitator
it's not sufficient to levitate then we
increase the power of the levitator the
particle goes up and then is trapped so
a particle let's do it again so that
when the particle lift is become trapped
all of a sudden at this location just
after the focus so that's the way an
optical tweezers works so let's now talk
about some of the biological application
that art himself measure so in 1987 art
and Joe digits is a technical assistant
set up a microscope to trap bacteria
using 11.06 micron neodymium YAG laser
so he started with non living organisms
and something that doesn't have the
shape of a sphere so here I'm going to
show a video where they took himself
where you can see this irregular
particle being moved by an optical
tweezer and you can see obviously that
is not circular but it's going to be
manipulated by the optical tweezers so
the laser is that's one micron so we
cannot see it's not visible but the one
is turned on it moves this small object
here so it shows that you don't need a
sphere to use optical tweezers to exert
force on objects then he it turns its
attention to living organisms so here's
a Paramecium a Paramecium is a
single-cell organism it is it is between
50 and 330 microns so it's fairly big it
has internal component called organelles
and they range from a few microns to a
few tens of microns
here's a video that art took where it
trapped one of the organelles I want to
attract your attention here to the white
dot which is an organelle and he's going
to trap them and trap the organelle
twice so let's look at the video so this
organelle is trapped and a Paramecium
will move and then when it is a the
organelle is the wall its exit the trap
and we're trapped again and when it eats
the wall its leave the trap again and
now let's look at what happens with
tobacco mosaic virus a tobacco mosaic
virus it's very long so it's very
different from a sphere so I want to
attract your attention here this
rectangle so the tobacco mosaic virus is
freeze moving around there's going to be
trapped so now it's trap doesn't move
and then it's turn in the inwards and
because it's trapped using by the end of
the virus because the end of the virus
refract light more and the optical
tweezers is stronger and now I decided
to trap spermatozoon and we can listen
to him describing what is doing this is
1988 may not well I don't know the power
might not be high enough or he's too
active
let me put up I'll give you well this is
about the maximum power let me say here
I'm moving him now I got a reference to
moving right here you can see our movie
nice work so now let's talk about a few
different applications so molecular
motors are biological molecules
molecular machines that are the
essential agent of movement in living
organism so here's example of the
keynesian the keynesian is a molecular
motor that can carry a load here a bead
has been attached to a Kinnison and the
keynesian is on a microtubule so the
keynesian want to transport that bead
and that bead is being trapped and an
optical tweezer and this optical tweezer
is soft in a sense that it traps the
bead but not too strongly so the bead is
kind of free to move a little bit and as
it moves the it change it deflects the B
is a beam of the tweezer so it can be
detected where the bead is in the
tweezer and if we look now at
measurements those are three different
measurements the step size here is this
is a function of time of the position of
the other bead and you can see the bead
move and by step size of eight
nanometers so the bead is kind of the
keynesian it's kind of walking along the
microtubule so it's making eight
nanometer step stop for a while and I
don't know let me just step and and so
on so now let's look now something a
little bit more advanced which is the
measurement of the DNA on DNA templates
so a DNA template is attached to one
bead which is in a trap then the RNA
polymerase is attached to another beat
also in the trap one of the trap is soft
it's let the bead move the other one is
strong the biddies doesn't move much or
at all and in the what we're going to
observe here is that the NRA polymerase
is transcribing the DNA and we're going
to see a video that is at 30 times the
speed of the tube it's moving from a
single DNA and single RNA polymerase in
action so the bead is moving as you can
see and what bring them together is the
RNA polymerase transcription so now if
we look at the measurements of this
distance between the beads this is a
measurement that is about 1,200 second
so we can zoom on it because there's a
very high resolution by a factor of 10
so we see yeah sometimes there's no
motion sometimes there's motion and if
we zoom even further we can see that now
they have steps of 3.4 Armstrong so to
perform Armstrong is only a few atoms
while and this 3.1 instrum corresponds
to the distance between the nucleotides
of the DNA there are other application
also of this of tweezers here are some
biopolymers properties motion and forces
of linear and rotary molecular motors
molecular behaviors of nucleic acid
enzymes folding in structured nucleic
acid in proteins protein binding and
Mikko manipulation a small object in
general and probably many more to come
there are also several companies selling
optical tweezers for different
application and different types of
tweezers
art also wrote a book in 2006 published
in 2006 I wrote it with the app of his
assistant of his wife Eileen represent
the fundamental of optical trapping I
discusses different bicycle applications
of optical tweezers it's also an
historical account of the development of
optical trapping around the world but
also at Balad so here are some other
people closest to him
George edges with whom he worked for
many decades
his wife of 64 years Allen and some of
his closest collaborators over the years
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]